[Music]
foreign
look at what's on the front pages as
they arrive in the next half hour we'll
see what's making the headlines with
Jake Wallace Simon's editor of the
Jewish Chronicle and Natalie Fey editor
of Nottinghamshire live
so let us see what's on some of those
front pages for you now well the Sunday
Telegraph leads with Liz truss saying
she was brought down by the left-wing
economic establishment
which she sunak is prepared to pull the
UK out of the European convention on
human rights that on the front page of
the Sunday Times
the Sunday Express reports that
thousands of lives are at risk after a
10-year cancer strategy was ditched
the first victim of a rapist and police
officer David Carrick reveals her
identity on the front page of the Sunday
people
and the star has the story of locals
protesting outside the bail hostel of
Gary Glitter following his release from
prison
a reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by Jake
Wallace Simon's editor of the Jewish
Chronicle and Natalie farahi editor of
Nottinghamshire live welcome to both of
you let's start with the times and uh
their headline U.S shoots down Chinese
spy balloon we've seen this play before
our very eyes this evening it was the
breaking news I'm not sure how much
you've seen of the the footage from this
evening Jake but but certainly a
dramatic conclusion to to that balloon
being over the coast of South Carolina
yes I mean I think the the most
extraordinary thing about this was that
it's a visual symbol finally of the um
of the undercover conflict I suppose
between the United States and China
that's been taking place in recent
decades frankly mostly that war has been
an economic War for dominance with China
seeking uh to use all manner of means
both overt and covert to gain economic
dominance both uh over the United States
and around the globe in Africa in South
America and elsewhere
um but also you know in terms of
Espionage and this was the first time
really for a very very long time indeed
that we've seen that uh actually come
out into the open with this spy balloon
that was the size of three school buses
uh floating merrily over sensitive
military sites in the states only to be
brought down by an American Sidewinder
missile so it does feel like the Chinese
pushing the envelope and seeing how much
they can get away with in provoking
America and seeing what the response
might be under this Biden Administration
Natalie that does have to be the
conclusion that that we uh we come to
because there was no way that the
Chinese would have thought this wouldn't
have been detected
yeah exactly I mean the whole thing is
quite ludicrous and you look on Twitter
and you're seeing all these sort of
memes emerge of people sitting in their
back Gardens with shotguns trying to
take you know shots at it and bring it
down which they're obviously warns not
to do but it's quite interesting that
these balloons can actually fly 150 000
feet whereas this one I think was flying
at 60 000 feet so the only the whole
idea behind it was to be spotted I mean
it was huge it had all this
paraphernalia solar panels surveillance
equipment uh suspended from the bottom
is a huge white balloon everyone was
filming it and spotting it so how could
you miss it it was absolutely huge and
that was obviously the intention behind
it
and Jake the question has to be now
where does this leave China's
relationship with the United States of
America we know that Anthony blinken was
due to to be there this weekend but that
trip was canceled because this balloon
was in a American airspace
that's right I mean certainly it does
call upon the Biden Administration to
act firmly
um but Biden Joe Biden is not known for
his term action in foreign policy unlike
his Predator predecessor uh Donald Trump
and it's interesting that these sorts of
provocations these sorts of
um episodes in which uh foreign
dictators test the United States are
happening more under Biden's watch as
they seek to see just how serious he
would be in laying down the law and of
course we've seen Ukraine happening
um you know the attack on Crimea
happened during Barack Obama's
administration nothing during the Trump
Administration now the Ukraine War uh
under Biden
um and the the sort of elephant in the
room is Taiwan that would be the next
step for China to take to invade Taiwan
and you can just see China testing the
water and seeing what the response is
going to be yes Natalie the the
president we heard from him this evening
saying that he'd actually given the
order on Wednesday to shoot the balloon
down so he's been quite emphatic and
obviously wanting to be seen as as very
strong in this
he has been yes and obviously we saw the
clip of him being questioned and he said
yes we're going to deal with it don't
worry but um we saw the Republicans
really um coming out strong I think
Donald Trump shouted on um whatever
social media platform he's using
nowadays just shoot it down
um but obviously we have to think about
the public you're on the ground there
was a lot of stuff attached to the
bottom of this balloon and um you know
painful as it was for people and to see
it floating slowly over the country
um they had to wait till it got over
water so it was safe and we could shoot
it on at that point and there was that
great video of all the bits on the
bottom falling into the sea which are
now rapidly being recovered so hopefully
the US can get some information out of
that uh massive backfire for China there
because we might get something useful
out of that
yes that recovery operation is uh you
suggest will be a well Minefield of
information that the Americans will want
to to tap into let's have a look at the
telegrapher and this story about uh Liz
truss our erstwhile prime minister and
she's I think this is probably her first
uh interview or uh article since she
left Downing Street and she's blaming
the left-wing economic establishment for
her demise Jake
yes I mean I think this this story is
really the marmalade dropper of of the
morning tomorrow
um Liz Strauss had written a 4 000 word
essay in the telegraph giving her a side
of what happened uh in her short-lived
uh Prime ministership and how it was
crashed and how it burned and she's
blaming a lot of different people she's
mainly blaming the economic
establishment in Whitehall which in her
view has a sort of left-wing bias
favoring high taxes and high spending of
the sort that we see now
um and it has a disproportionate
influence on the markets and so that
sort of works against her when she tried
to implement her more radical plans uh
she blames some other people and
entities as well she blames her
predecessors Boris Johnson uh Theresa
May and David Cameron for not
sufficiently imbibing the party in the
country with a respect for a low tax
approach instead allowing the creep of
high-tax culture to to overtake the UK
um and she criticizes the treasury
officials as well and spaz advisors for
not warning her about the pension crisis
that would follow her policies which
would then trigger the guilt crisis and
everything else that we know so a lot of
blame going around and I do have some
sympathy for her we do need growth in
this country we do need to go back to a
sense of having taxes under control and
lower and public spending under control
as well but I think that she fails to
recognize that the main problem was that
her tax cuts were unfunded and that was
above everything else that was what
really spooked the markets and also of
course you know if she shouldn't have
been surprised by this opposition that
she faced she'd been in you know in
politics and in government for a very
long time it can't have been any
surprise to her that Whitehall was
dominated by what she called after being
economic Orthodoxy uh Natalie does she
accept any personal responsibility at
all anywhere in this uh 3 000 word essay
no she doesn't seem to and even the
picture of her there is a massive
picture she looks quite smart I think
it'd be fair to say
um I thought the sort of um there was a
couple of killer bits in there really
um where she even seemed to blame the
public for not having an understanding
of tax and economic policies nowadays
which you know is quite harsh really and
there was this sort of killer line at
the end there where just slid in senior
government saw said Miss truss's
approach failed then and will fail have
tried again so just a massive warning
don't try to make a comeback
do you think that this is the the
beginning of a comeback for the former
prime minister is this her way of uh
drawing a line under what happened and
saying I'm here and I'm up for business
once more
I I don't think it's her trying to make
a comeback as such but I think it's
certainly an attempt to destabilize uh
Rishi sunak who's already becoming a
little bit destabilized anyway we've
heard lots of talk of all the WhatsApp
messages have been buzzing around the
groups coming back to life that brought
her to power in the first place she's
doing a massive talk on China she's sort
of maneuvering again and she's doing a
big TV interview with well we don't know
who apparently the BBC bid for it and
it's gone to arrival I don't know if
it's going to be Sky News maybe it will
be or somebody else
um so it's not come back as such but
it's kind of uh you know don't forget
about me I'm still here and I was right
so don't forget it Jake just very
quickly do you think she is trying to
undermine uh Rishi suneck he's not
mentioned by name anywhere is he
he's not mentioned by name uh but I
think that really what she's trying to
do is to
um influence the direction of policy uh
more in her favor in terms of this
growth agenda we've seen the emergence
recently of a pro-growth caucus of Tory
MPS which is gaining Steam and gaining
momentum uh inside the Parliamentary
party and Liz truss of course is the
absolute Paragon of that kind of
pro-growth ideology although as we've
seen the implementation of that ideology
was very badly done and ended up with a
disaster but I think that she is
definitely trying to undermine Rishi
sunak's attempt to enforce this sort of
Centrist you know High tax
um Britain and you know with her
slinging hand grenades from one side and
Boris from the other it does make Rich
unex job a lot harder as the next
election Looms
which moves us on to the express and
they have the headline there voters say
rishi's better than Boris but not secure
polling reveals strong support for a
snap election within the next six weeks
Natalie
um yeah I was surprised to read that I
mean who who would really want an
election in the next six weeks I think
we're all just happy having a bit of
calm uh for now but this poll uh which
is carried out by Redfield and Wilson
strategies
um so 32 back to Rishi soon act to be
prime minister but interesting 14 didn't
know out of here and Rishi who then
kirst armor the labor lead obviously who
they would want uh to be prime minister
so people are massively undecided and um
you know
um they they do think the Rishi is
better than Boris which I suppose is
some comfort to um everything we went to
last year doesn't look like Boris
popular among people wouldn't be
potentially making a comeback but you
know if we did have an election soon
it's looking like there is going to be
one next year
it's going to be a tight one I think
probably because people just don't know
who they want to vote for
but Jacob Rishi sunak isn't going to be
up against Boris Johnson in a general
election it will be secure starmer who
he doesn't seem to be faring very well
against according to this poll at least
yes I mean there's two two lessons come
out of this really the first is that you
know Boris has got some support within
the Tory party a growing level of
support
behind the idea of him making a comeback
because he's this proven election winner
that's the sort of idea that's that's
floating around and this suggests that
that might be misguided as he only
gained 27 support against a much higher
score for Richard sunag but then the
other lesson is that Rishi is polling uh
lower than kirst armor at the moment
kirst armor on 40 and Rishi on 32
according to this poll but something
like 48 of people didn't know which was
better and that's got to be encouraging
horishi sudak because at this point
given everything that's happened
recently uh not just in terms of Boris
Johnson Liz truss and all the party gate
and all the rest of it but also the
sleeves that's dog the tour party in
recent weeks you would have thought that
Kirsten would be further ahead than he
is and you would have thought there
wouldn't be so many people who are
basically swing voters who are undecided
in the middle and so it does feel like
they're is a small window through which
she might where she might be able to
squeak in 2024. just a bit more detail
of saying that the poll more than
two-thirds of people 67 think there's a
culture of sleaze this follows nadims
are we being sacked as party chairman
for a serious breach of the ministerial
code after failing to disclose his tax
Affairs were under investigation only 27
said Mr sunac had upheld values of
Integrity professionalism and
accountability remember that those are
values that he said at the beginning of
his term that he would uphold for the
moment Jake and Natalie thank you both
we are going to take a break coming up
we'll take a look at the express front
page featuring the police appeal for a
new witness in the Nickelodeon case stay
with us
foreign
[Music]
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview still with me Jake Wallace
Simon's editor of the Jewish Chronicle
and Natalie FYE editor of
Nottinghamshire live welcome back to
both of you let's take a look at the
times and they're reporting it that uh
Rishi soon acts threatening to pull the
UK out of the European convention on
human rights take us into the detail of
this story Jake
yeah so this is the prime minister and
Sola brathman the Home Secretary trying
very much to uh get to grips with this
small boats crisis
um there's predicted to be 65 000 people
coming over this coming year as opposed
to 45 000 last years that's an uplift
almost 50 so these numbers are really
spiraling out of control they're trying
to get equipped with it and the latest
proposal is to legislate uh to me that
anybody coming illegally from France to
Britain uh will be unable to claim
Asylum so this is a a bold legal move by
the government and what they're trying
to do is to predict the obstacles that
might arise to that being implemented uh
as we've seen in the past as obstacles
come from many sources and they include
from human rights lawyers in Britain uh
trying to appeal against against that
ruling they're trying to legislate for
that not to be possible either but now
they're looking at the European
convention for human rights so that if
British judges are able to pass that
legislation so that it wouldn't be
overturned by Strasbourg by the European
Court of Human Rights there there's been
talk before
um in recent years by Tory governments
about withdrawing from the European
conventional human rights and replacing
it with a British Bill of Rights and
that at that time it was mainly about
the deportation of foreign criminals so
this is another manifestation of that
same idea and really what they're trying
to do is to preempt all of the possible
obstacles to the implementation of this
policy with uh with an aim of really
trying to get on top of this crisis now
nothing there is likely to be a legal
challenge to this though isn't there
of course there will be I mean we've
seen so many hurdles to the government
getting through immigration policies
over the past couple of years
um it's not going to be an easy path for
them whatever they try to do and it says
and they're the finalizing plans for the
most Draconian immigration legislation
seen in this country
um so you know it's obviously going to
be something along the lines of what we
saw uh when the government attempted to
put illegal immigrants on a plane to
Rwanda something along those lines
possibly
um but the government obviously realizes
that this is an incredibly important
issue for voters you don't need to read
that piece in the times to know that you
just have to speak to people on the
street uh speak to members of your
family people just want the government
to take control of it do something make
sure that the people coming into this
country have a genuine reason to be here
and
um you know to make sure that people
who've been put in hotels have somewhere
safe to go that they're sorted correctly
processed correctly and that they're in
safe living conditions and they can
either stay here or they're not allowed
to stay here at the moment it all feels
quite chaotic and it's quite right that
the government is um taking trying to
take control of it but we'll see what
happens Jake to the Express and the
latest in the search for Nicola bully
police looking for a new key Witness
that's right I mean this this is such a
um a heartbreaking case and I think at
the center of it really is this mystery
of what happened to you there's such
little evidence to go on all the police
have at the moment is this hypothesis
that she probably fell into the river
while trying to retrieve a tennis ball
and drowned on a on account of wearing
two coats that became waterlogged but
they don't actually know and now they're
appealing for this particular witness a
woman in a yellow coat who is pushing a
push chair along the river path around
the time when Nicola disappeared they're
appealing for her they're also appealing
for any drivers who might possibly have
dash cam footage from around the area at
the time when she disappeared as well to
Rack their brains if they've got any
footage at all to come forward and the
sun has reported that they're also
seeking to analyze data from Nicholas
Fitbit as well see if that shares any
light on the situation so a tragic and
heartbreaking case we can only hope that
at the very least we get some idea of
just what happened to Paul Nicholas yes
we're very painful for the family that's
what we're all uh praying for
um let's have a look at this story The
the last one I think we'll have time for
in the express this is Page seven of the
express and it's the Princess of Wales
she's a shared a photo of herself as a
child why Natalie
um well that's an absolutely adorable
photo it's a photo of the Princess of
Wales reaching for her father's face
Michael Middleton and Middleton and the
pictures taken by Kate Middleton's
mother Carol and this is to publicize
the launch of Princess Sofia's new
campaign to
um highlight how important early years
are children and faces are um young
children's favorite toys that's what she
says and I think she's probably right uh
children do love and babies do have
grabbing faces and looking at faces and
they learn a lot from people's
Expressions so you know great campaign
from the Princess of Wales but I think
what people are saying is we could do
some cash and some investment as well as
the awareness
um so maybe we'll see a bit of that as
well that would be good yeah sir Jake um
wondering if you feel that we we need
perhaps or what campaigners are saying
they need more than
um
pictures and awareness that there does
need to be some injection of money to
have real change
well I mean I've always been one of
those who believes very much in the
importance of early childhood and and
early childhood care
um and uh I do think that um the the
drive to get women out to work as early
as possible
um I think is is mistaken because I
think it's it's bad for Child
Development and I think that that has
long-term implications for society so I
do welcome
um uh Princess Kate's uh campaign I
think she's doing a very Noble thing in
drawing attention to this